every oscar win represents a
life-changing moment while all are
significant some are historic
for her spectacular afrofuturistic looks
in black panther ruth made history as
she became the first black costume
designer to win an oscar
it's an honor to design costumes that
reimagine beauty
empower the female form
express diversity in storytelling
and turn a superhero into an african
king
let's pay tribute to the outstanding
visual storytellers who have shown us
new worlds through costumes
that's you oh i'm
i'm used to being behind the camera
i'm proud to present the nominees for
achievement in costume design
cruella costume designed by jimmy bevin
[Applause]
cyrano costume designed by massimo
cattini perrini and jacqueline durin
dune costume designed by jacqueline west
and robert morgan
nightmare alley costume designed by
louis sequira
[Applause]
west side story costume designed by paul
taswell
and the oscar goes to
jenny bevin
this is the third oscar and 11th
nomination for jenny bevin who took home
oscars for her work on mad max fury road
and a room with a view
[Applause]
[Music]
team cruella go team cruella now if you
heard a really embarrassing noise it was
probably my family who are somewhere up
there who supported me through this
extraordinary experience um which had
massive amounts of fun as you can see
but also was slightly stressful and the
only one i'm missing is my darling um
son-in-law david who used to give me
good advice at the end of every day but
he's no longer with us anyway um i just
thought i should explain um i obviously
didn't go down well last time this is an
honoring uh my inner cruella and a
little bit of mazda moxon random lapel
tom davis eyewear tom boxwood um
graffiti
and
i have to say when um christian bear and
craig gillespie asked me to do this
movie i truly didn't think we had time i
mean i actually nearly said no glad i
didn't the only reason i didn't was
because claire swagg who's sitting just
there sparkling um said she would come
on board as costume supervisor
and bring the team the team of the most
phenomenal
creative
clever
generous amazing people i mean without
him obviously it wouldn't have happened
and i also need to thank nadia and naomi
and julia our makeup and hair team
because they complete the looks i mean
you know it would be a little sad
putting a cruella costume with my hair
but also the actors who just brought
such life i think emma thompson
hyperventilating over some of her
fittings with joy was one of the
highlights of my career anyway i think
that's all i kind of of course left the
thing in the car and have to write it
all on here but i think i probably
remember people have made such wonderful
speeches but the lovely thing i think
about a film like cruella is it does
bring a bit of fun and joy in these
terrible times which others have
mentioned but you know it
it was great to do and thank you academy
thank you
you